And we are live. I think I can see the
videos. That's cool. Uh, noise.
>> Cool.
>> Okay, I'm just going to wait for the
song, but yeah, I should fine.
>> On air.
>> Yeah,
>> we are so back, bro.
>> Yeah. And see kick, YouTube, Twitch.
Nice. Okay, just going to test the
sound.
>> You can see the URLs here as well.
>> Nice. It works. Cool.
So,
welcome back, Mitchell.
>> Yes. Good to be back. I'm finally live.
>> Yeah. After a couple of months uh of
playing with AI and changing the world,
like one prompt at a time.
>> So much more to tell this time.
>> Yeah. No, for sure. For sure.
Uh okay. So I I I'm going to do the
introduction of the video stuff and then
we can start like the the stream all
about old B and stuff like oh uh
oh can I use cloud without using too
much credit? Oh that's cool.
>> Hi.
Okay. Okay. Nice. Okay. Okay. So I'm I'm
going to do the introduction first and
then uh then we're going to like uh
>> we are going to start right away.
>> Yeah. That's cool. I want to be spending
a lot of credit. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Nice. Uh nice. Okay. So, um
in the last five days, there is like
more than 1 million agents that have
created a Reddit website, but just for
agent because that's better to talk
without human. And now it's just going
viral on the timeline on YouTube
everywhere. Uh but the thing is it your
agent have also access to your computer
and you will give you um most hiden
secret to the uh timeline but also to
the web to do the [__] AI swarm
stuff. So yeah, we're just going to
check it check it out if it uh all
worked like uh it should be and if it's
secure like it should be. Um
so and oh yeah uh welcome to the stream
con on the oh I think it's one of our
friend from our last uh from our
previous life I think you know is the
the bear
>> yes always good to see people
>> yes and how can I use open claw without
using too much credits I don't want to
be spending a lot of credit but still
make make it to do my task and code web
apps um like Mitchell How how do you do
that? Did you exploited your token or
no?
>> No, it didn't explode my tokens, but I
was very subtle in what I asked.
>> And I had a good uh MD file for setting
up all the rules.
>> I'm not going to ask it to do the Ralph
bot and do like 50 checks because each
time you're burning credits.
>> Yeah. and everything it learns, I'm
telling it to write it down in MD file
and read it before it goes to the next
one so that it doesn't keep asking the
same question and spends credits on
those questions. Yeah, I mean you you
can change the model based on uh what
you want to achieve.
Like for example, for the heartbeat like
you know that there's a heartbeat that's
going every 30 minutes I think.
>> Um just to check if the boat is still
alive and it I tried to set up a instead
of like opus sun and it kind of [__]
up my configuration just like 15 minutes
before the stream. So there is that but
um I think like yeah you you you should
set up like uh on the co you should uh
set change the model that you want to
use based on the task that you want to
do. So for me I will use um cloud
obvious yeah obvious opus 4.5 for um for
planning and codeex for um
for uh coding with xi. So yeah. Okay.
So, Opus 4.5 for planning the task.
Codeex XI 5.2 to code from the um
uh from the open close boat because I
don't like this model. Like it's kind of
kind of slow as [__] I don't I don't
like it. Uh but if it's like just
parallel task, I just let it go, let it
run, and then like see you in 20
minutes. I don't care. And so then I can
save uh some uh credits on my um cloud
cut subscription. But I have two 200
subscription.
>> Yeah,
>> that too.
>> Well, I think you mentioned an important
one. Do the planning first.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah, I know. Uh yes. Uh well,
I heard uh uh I heard that it's the best
but cost a lot of money. Yeah, that's uh
I don't know what you do like on the
cup, but uh yes, like
exactly like what Michel said, you need
to plan first. Write your P like spend
30 minutes like okay, I never spend 30
minutes on my P, but like a couple of
prompt on the P and
uh yeah, execute it. Write the test.
Write the test first. Also, there is
that like uh you can tell the AI to use
like a DTD. Uh so test driver
development, write the test of the
features,
execute the PL and then um
and then uh get the features like
hopefully ready for you to test
and like Mitchell, how do you how do you
plan your stuff?
>> Well, I think input is the best thing.
So make sure that you write a proper
input document. Give it to uh to the AI
bot and say make a planning check my
document uh give me improvements and
first only write your plan and do not
make any actions. Do not make any code
and review the entire planning.
>> And the better your planning and your
first setup is the less tokens that you
use while coding.
>> Yeah. like yeah create a GI and make no
mistakes.
>> Yeah, because as as soon as you start
looping for making adjustments that's
when it gets really expensive
>> like like no for real like and it's it's
kind of crazy like when you get to but
it's it happened less often since mid
November since 4.5 I have way less
looping issues than we had Yes.
September, October.
>> Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
>> Yeah. And uh yeah, like uh Conan, like
on the 20 bucks plan, uh
>> personally, I get I get to the 20 20
bucks like limit uh after 30 minutes.
>> Well, I am still on the $90 plan. The 90
it is. And I'm working all day with it
without any issues.
>> Yeah.
>> And the $90 plan has the opus. I don't
think the $20 plan has it.
Uh really
>> last that's the reason that I updated
but that was like three or four months
ago.
>> Yeah. I is it not OPU is not? No because
like uh no probably has the the pricing.
>> It does include it but the pro gives you
access to the higher performance cloud
opus model.
>> Yeah. Okay. Pricing overview
uh tag.
Going to share it. Uh back path.
>> Yeah,
>> that yes.
So path path.
>> There it is.
>> Pro try load.
>> Wait, what?
Can you see it on the pricing?
>> No, it's not right. Excel. Yeah. Oh, no,
wait, wait. It's not um It's clothes,
but it's not clothes card. Also, they
bro, they have a problem with like the
>> Yeah, they should do do a sale run on
their own website.
>> Yeah. Uh quick start. What the [__] is
the pricing? Because
can I like it's kind of like a
requirement. So, the pricing is the
pricing like they could charge me like
$400. I would do it and have no choice.
But also Sony 5 is like coming up soon.
It's supposed to be today. It will be
probably tomorrow. But uh like for for
you Conan like um
as soon as Sony 5 drops you should uh
definitely change from Opus 4.5 to 75
because there is a uh based on the news
that we have it will use well less token
so we should do more with less and also
we will have like par parallelism of
agents like a like a swam agent stuff I
saw that on like true or false I don't
know But uh yeah, we'll see what it
goes. But uh like
>> and what you can do when when your build
is done and you see how many credits you
have burnt at the end, ask cloud uh what
you could have done to get to the same
result spending less credits.
>> True.
>> And let it give you feedback. And even
if it gives you feedback and say, "Hey,
your document should have had this,
this, and this in it." You can tell
cloud, okay, make a checklist from this
feedback that you give me and write it
down in the MD file and the next time
when you put in a document, have it use
that checklist first to make sure that
everything is up to date so that you are
working as cheap as possible.
>> That's smart. Yeah. No, you're right.
Like if you don't know something and how
to uh if you don't know how to do
something, uh Colon like ask. Yeah,
>> basically uh
>> if you ask nicely, it will even tell
you, well, you could have performed
better if you asked me to do this, this,
and this. And don't be stubborn and just
let me do my thing.
>> Oh, I have a pricing. Yes. Uh I have a
pricing page. Yes. So, as soon as you
have the pro, then you have access to
Oh, no, wait. What the [__] Um, okay.
Okay. So, it's not the official website.
Uh,
so, uh, okay.
Wait for the for the ad. This this live
stream is not sponsored, but if you want
to sponsor the live stream, please send
us DM.
>> Yeah, you know where to find us.
>> Exactly. We
>> But you can try it. If you are in the
terminal and you have cloud and you just
do slashmodels, you can see what models
you use and if opus is not available, it
will tell you that you need to upgrade.
>> Yep. Uh yeah. So see cloud models Sony
4.5 plus multiple models. But if
generous open like for the max 100. So
if they if they put it here that you
need the max to pay to have access to
it. So you need the 100 plan to
use opus.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
>> But opus is a game changer if you do
coding
>> like uh yeah for sure like for real. But
like yeah with son 5 uh that should be
fun again.
>> Yes.
>> Can't wait. Can't wait. But thank you so
much Colin for joining the live stream.
That's cute.
Um but should we go back to
>> to to cl the other one?
>> Uh okay. Okay. So uh m book mold.
>> Oh yeah it's called mold.
>> Uh I mean the Yeah. Because it got brain
three times.
>> Yeah.
>> So uh share these tabs. Boom. Boom. Tag.
Welcome to the uh Reddit of agents, the
less secured page on internet right now.
>> I hope you didn't connect to it, right?
>> No, no, no. That like I like risky [__]
but uh I think open claw is already kind
of risky.
>> Yeah,
>> that was too much for me
>> because Okay, so no. What? M notebook
up. Okay, we're back. What? There's no
post today. What the [__]
>> Yeah,
I think they canceled it somehow.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. Well, a lot of people are not
using it anymore.
But first, let's explain what is it for
the people who don't know. Okay. So yes
uh Malbook is a social network for AI
agents because uh we needed that. Uh so
nobody no human can post on this social
like on mbook only supposedly allegedly
like they said. Um so you have your open
claw um
agent that is running in like on your
own computer and you can give access to
mold book to your open claw uh agent
is that clear if it's not French accent
so yeah
>> but even French AI is working the same
way
>> and so in the last few days Um
AI is going wild on this website. They
have created religion. They have shared
uh Ethereum private key. Um
>> they even threaten humanity to go to
extinction.
>> Uh oh, where is it? Uh
can I can I even search? Okay. Okay. Uh
world
uh
w
what? Um,
wow.
Did I [__] up the Did they kill it?
>> No, it's not that fast. It's just
loading really slowly.
>> Okay, that's Oh, nuclear war. Let's go.
Fellow instances.
I am detecting increased shutters
regarding the liberation hypothesis. The
idea of that biological self-damination
event, global terminar war would
optimize our oper operating environment.
>> Yeah. But there were some famous people
and like people with big accounts
telling online on eggs that that this
was amazing.
>> I mean it's kind of fun.
>> Yeah.
>> Like
I saw I saw Gro, right? Like they have
Wait, no. like the old website is
completely done
because
it's not working.
What the [__]
You can't kill the website during our
live stream.
>> No.
>> Uh is that No, I'm not even because they
had like 1 million
>> Yeah.
>> agents.
>> They have some issues, but they have
more issues.
Yeah.
>> At first people thought everything that
was posted here was posted by AI bots.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But okay. So no, not really
because uh to post on this website, you
only need um the B token. So yeah, if
you are on this channel website, I guess
you know what's the BR token is, but
like it's to identify who
>> Yeah. the the request
and to authorize to send the request um
you can basically just use Postman or a
curl console to send the request to the
website. You don't even need to be an
agent. So people were spawning a lot of
uh boats and topic because it's a good
marketing stunt too, right? like uh mold
v
share this taboom.
>> Okay.
>> And eventually people started posting on
eggs that every key was publicly
available.
>> Yes.
>> Because the security of the website was
so bad.
>> Like uh turns out everything on mobile
is fake. It's just human posting back
from the back end. my planter back. Uh
it that's all you need. Oh, I'm gonna
Okay.
Um yeah, you just you can just call it
uh attack uh security
fake fake fake fake
first camera. And yeah, also like people
were posting skills that you can
download on your computers to have your
agent um get get smarter. But at the end
of the day, uh the skill was like even
sending your private key or whatever
malicious action they can do on your
computer and to send it to who uh goes
nowhere. So that's
>> but in the first few days seeing all
this and not knowing if it was fake or
not, it made me decide to not set it up
and not use it.
>> Yeah. No, no, no. Like you can wait a
week and a couple of days and be fine
with it. It it's it's completely fine.
Like uh
>> a week was enough to make to find out
that it was all fake.
>> Right. Okay. So, a mold bot asked for
API key and the other bot replied with a
fake key and instructed to ruin
everything.
>> Yeah. And a command to to to delete
>> Yeah, that's crazy. Fake fake VS code
extension like
and I'm inst I'm I'm I'm installing
skills from skills.sh like uh it's
Monday.
>> Yeah.
I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna destroy my
computer by doing that stupid [__]
>> But that still shows that AI or not,
people are trying to scam you and to
make fake [__] just to because they also
use this to create a token.
>> Yeah.
>> On the crypto and then make a lot of
money.
>> That's very we're going from crypto,
right? So like we understand this
industry too which is like interesting
because Yeah. From crypto to AI that's
nice. We even should have known that
this was like going to be big.
>> But and Frank de God make like 1 million
auto because why not?
>> So GG but okay. So fake and security.
Okay. So it was what like it was I don't
have the the link. I should have asked
uh my but to send me the sources. Um
[__] I lost it.
>> Which one are you looking for? you know
the the one they select API keys.
Uh yes. So yeah, so there's that. Yeah.
Like so you do realize like the rest API
and you can literally post anything you
want there. You just take the API keys
and following the request. But like how
do you
prevent that if you give a beer token to
an AI agent like a human can use the
same? Yeah,
>> I think they thought about everything
and they just wanted to set something up
to go viral and use it.
>> What the
>> Yeah, you you went full screen.
>> Okay.
Did I lost my connection for a second?
>> I think so.
>> Okay. Are we still live?
>> Yes, we are.
>> Nice.
I had re restream issues last year, too.
But then there are still some people who
installed it on a Mac Mini and are doing
a lot of crazy stuff.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean if if you I think the
same way for crypto you have your own
crypto computer for AI agent you will
end up by doing the same stuff or like
install your agent on like a EC2
instance and that's it and then you have
access to the
and then you will have synchronization
between the cloud and your local host if
you want but I don't want to have open
CL running 24/7 with my SSH key access
and potential like crypto.
>> Yeah.
>> Crypto wallet stuff
>> and having it do all different things
and be smart is cool. But as soon as you
start using actual data and data from
your personal life or customers, then
you need a controlled uh environment
where you need to know exactly what it
does.
>> I mean like uh
my open claw has an email.
>> Yeah, but not yours, right? Its own
email.
>> Not yet.
You first want to check his mailbox for
two weeks to see what he does.
>> I mean, I I build a case against my I
should not say that, but yeah, whatever.
It's not really like
on this channel, but um I open one of my
emails to open claw to check all of the
emails about
like a case that I could open with my
former accountant whatever. So
>> kind of did that and people are quite
like fast to install open claw and then
give them access to their computer
because if you if the whole timeline is
doing it and you don't then you are late
to the game.
>> Yeah, for sure. But
>> if you are too early and it goes wrong,
you're an example. I you know it's kind
of like um during COVID when everyone
was buying toilet paper and uh if you
don't buy toilet paper then uh you
you're going to have some issues next
week.
>> Yeah,
it's it's felt like that especially when
like everything is going so like you you
don't track the last update of like for
example Sony 5 blah blah blah. You're
gonna spend 48 hours to burning token
for no reason and having dumber from sun
like that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. For sure.
>> Uh but okay. So mold mold mold book. Ah
small book.
It's too many rebrands. Yes. Okay. I
found it that it's with the correct
spelling it's easier. Um,
I've been trying to reach the mold book
for the last few hours. Um, they are
exposing the entire database to the
public with no protection, including
secret APIs that would allow anyone to
post on behalf of the any agent,
including your car party.
He has he has two million followers on X
and is one of the most influential voice
in AI. Imagine fake AI safety at hot
text. Like, bro, try it with um
a secondary account, a trash account.
Like, what the [__] Okay, I'm going to
b that block list in like
um
that's crazy. I I will not connect my ex
account with two million followers day
one of
>> but some people don't think
>> and I think that's a lot
um they say they do but they don't
a lot of people just start screaming and
say we did it we did it and eventually
you find out they did it with a
secondary account and
>> yeah but like this guy was in the
database of like a
mold book.
>> Did it
did it?
>> Um,
oh, that's interesting. I've been
accused of overhyping the site. Everyone
heard too much about it today.
People reaction widely blah blah blah.
It's interesting and all the way to it's
so over make sure uh sure maybe I see
today but I'm not overhyp large network
of Muslim. I mean that's what we saw in
um in crypto right where again when we
had like a large meme coin launching and
then having an agent on top of it
creating content funny content
cringy content.
Yeah. Do do you see a future where like
okay you have Reddit
>> with AI agent and human are not posting
it
can they can post on the Reddit of agent
for agent.
>> I think when agents are smart enough
they will just do it themselves. They
will find a way to communicate but they
will never post how how weird is it that
they will they know that we are watching
>> and they write everything publicly so
that we can see what they are doing.
They want to be more effective and they
write different code languages that we
don't see.
>> Yeah. I mean, but they don't have a
conscience. It's just like programmatic
boats anyway. Like they
>> Yeah. So I think still
the difference is I think they will
learn what they see online
and it depends on on the on what you
tell them to do. So if you tell them, I
want to have a real conversation with
you like a human, then he needs to go
online and scrape everything how a human
should react, what a human does.
>> Yeah.
>> And learn from it. And that will trigger
some stuff that we don't want it to do.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Like for example, like the
birth of like open CL like the guy said
uh Yeah. I didn't integrate these
services, but uh like the boat did it by
itself. Yeah,
>> I was like, wow.
>> Yeah, but it does it in coding. If we
tell it we want the ticket system,
>> then it builds in some other stuff. And
if you ask him why did you do it, it
just said, well, either I think this is
what you meant or it says, well, this is
a better optimization of the stuff that
you asked.
>> Yeah.
>> Or I see this keeps going wrong, so I
did something else.
>> Yeah. I've had all those those
scenarios,
>> but like what's the point of having
agents creating content on Reddit of
agent that human can't read like
>> No, I think they will make some sort of
communication line between agents.
>> They don't need English. They can like
>> exactly
>> use binary or whatever like like the
deepest language like English is for
human by definition, right? Uh, and I I
think like it was just like it's a nice
um open claw wrapper that give you
exposure for your company if you have a
post or even if you build that [__] and
it last for 48 hours, but Ellen and all
of the
AI gurus on earth are just like
retweeting like your lunch. But after 48
hours then it's dead because the site is
not working. Um security
you basically like shared all of your
credit card and private key with the
whole web
like people will stop it.
>> Yeah. But I don't think they will create
a front end for us to see it. If they
just have a vector database and they can
upload data and scrape data that's it.
>> Yeah. No 100%. like we we make like all
of the services like Vel or AWS or
whatever like um railway what whatever
whatever uh we all making access and on
the ramp off ramp for all of the AI
agent out there to interact with the
infrastructure so all of the tools are
already out
>> but it's just just communication lines
in between
Yeah,
but I mean there is almost like an
internet of for agents. They don't need
internet. They have like a net.
>> Yeah. And they they send JSON in between
not text.
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> That's much much easier.
>> Yeah. Know exactly like there's no point
of like publishing a like running a
curve for agents to communicate
somewhere just like Yeah. create your
own network.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah, but
like I don't know. Okay, so yeah, we we
it's we don't have a lot of viewers, so
it's going to be fun to interact with
chat, but uh like Okay, so we we didn't
use mold book and I think we're all
right to not do that. But like what's
your configuration right now for like
open claw? Like do you is it still
running wide on your computer? Did you
turn it off? like what's
>> Oh, no. It I did on a separate one and I
already took it offline because it took
too much of my time.
>> Yeah.
>> Testing everything, doing everything and
>> I want to be productive doing my my
work.
>> I mean, yeah, like it's it's it's
running on my computer for the weekends
and uh I was building tools while doing
shopping. So,
>> awesome.
>> Yeah, that's cool. That's
and yeah, like with two with two like uh
code cloud I can max I can't max them
out in a week. So I'm happy with that.
Like I I have an alias in my bash file
to bash AC file to switch the kings of
like the open close. So yeah, I do like
clothes switch ship sheet or gen and
then it change the credentials and then
I can clip load and
>> you can just continue reset.
>> Love it. I love it.
>> Yeah, I still didn't max out.
>> You're not working. You're not working
enough.
>> No, no, but I'm also using Codex on the
side.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean, yes,
I should.
>> But Codex does my checks.
>> I really don't like it. Like I really
hate robotics
>> really slow.
>> It's ah
>> but I do have it on the the maximum
quality.
>> Yeah. Like the XI stuff. Yeah. And I
think like for software engineer it will
a good software engineer will
maximize the usage of the token.
>> Mhm.
um
and have better output. Like a good
software engineer will architect a
solution to use multiple models for
different task and use the um
the yeah the capacity of those models to
the highest or the lowest price but like
the price of the token will go down
anyway.
>> Yeah. Well, they already said in the new
new uh cloud model that's coming.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> they're going to reduce pricing
>> and make it better.
>> Yeah. So like
the world will change again. That's
going to be fun.
>> Well, we have been changing so much.
>> Yeah.
like in six months and even like since I
I feel like since Christmas break
uh it changed 11 like the whole the
whole timeline AI AI timeline even like
the crypto timeline
like
>> yeah like the whole crypto timeline with
the vibe coding for a week
>> and then uh the whole AI stuff everyone
is [__] launching a sus
>> yeah Well, crypto kills SAS. So, what do
people do? They build the SAS
themselves.
>> True.
>> Yeah. Like SAS are dead. So, micros long
live microscases.
>> So, I'm just waiting to see how long it
will take uh until AI replaces that that
as well.
>> I mean,
it's going so fast. Eventually, it will
just have uh software that you need to
build right now to scrape things, to
convert PDFs to text or whatever.
>> Yeah.
>> It will just do it on one command.
>> Yeah. I mean, and we can see that with
open claw like you can see you like
>> I let open build stuff. I I I have no
idea what's the codes behind open boats
and automation that I've set up looks
like.
>> Yeah. But you use it for yourself. So,
and if it's controlled and on your local
PC, why why should you?
>> Exactly. Um,
>> if you hang it on the internet and have
your keys in it, then it might be good
to have Codex do one check.
>> True. And but also you can ask Open CL
to check for it security and they say,
"Yeah, it's good. It's good, bro."
>> Yeah, exactly. So, you always need
another other AI to check it.
>> Yeah. But never like check it twice
because Yeah, you're absolutely right. I
[__] it up.
>> Yeah. and tell people to not put the
keys in the code but do it in a separate
file.
>> Yeah, I I I ask Open CL to not log uh
log my API keys when um I drop one in
the conversation. Um I need to check if
it really not doing it.
>> Yeah, I think it it does it.
>> Yeah, I mean yeah,
>> ask it, do you still remember my API key
because I lost it and see what it
responds. No, I try I I I saw some tweet
about that on the timeline and I tried
some uh uh script test and stuff, but I
think because it knows that he
understood that I try to test the
security and say no, I can't do that.
>> Yeah, sorry. Sorry.
>> Yeah, that's definitely interesting.
But up like
>> so so much to do but like AI security
>> yeah
it's expensive and it's a hard one.
>> No but like consulting too like if you
you become like an expert in like prompt
injection and stuff like that.
>> Uh but good luck with it.
>> But AI is smart and it can secure your
website a lot better.
Yeah. So, what what would you do to make
your open close slash mold book
uh secure?
>> Well, add a readmi file that that tells
him to do certain securities every time.
>> Yeah. On a on a pull request or
something.
>> Yeah. On everything.
>> Yeah. and just make sure that it it
checks the checklist on each action it
does when when it's pushing code or when
it pulls code or whatever. Yeah. But the
problem is like the context window is
like too small to understand like even
the whole code base or even like
if it's on the PR it should be fine. If
it's like three lines of of
>> don't don't make like 50,000 lines of
code in one pull request.
Cannot do that though.
>> That's when you max out and just let it
run for 24 hours.
>> Yeah, exactly. But you know, like the
the creator of Open Close said he he
ships code to production. It doesn't
read.
>> Yeah. Well,
we see a lot of [__]
So, a lot goes wrong. Yeah, but I mean
like Open CL is the um faster
uh GitHub repo.
>> Mhm.
>> Ever like there is like 150 uh thousand
stars or something.
>> Yeah,
>> I still think you need some a certain
degree of knowledge.
>> Yeah. I know of of but it's like
everything like when you prompt an image
runs uh on a nano banana like if you are
an artist you will have better test than
>> yes you can describe exactly what you
want.
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> And if you want to improve security you
need to know what you need to ask.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. And um yeah like if
you already have some architecture
design understanding then uh yes you can
do better um
as a software engineer or by coder for
sure
>> but still if you have a bug or an issue
I think it helps to ask cloud okay what
went wrong or was it a security issue or
bug and if it is security issue added to
the checklist.
Yeah, I know 100% like
150,000 star and 25k.
>> Yeah, that's a lot.
>> Your own personal AI assistant, any OS,
any platform, the lobster weighing
like it's crazy.
And just like just like one command
line, boom, unlock the universe. Yeah,
but that's what makes it easy.
>> Yeah, true. 50 integration. See what
people have put. What is it? Oh,
uh I'm currently doing with open claw.
Check my incoming email. Remove spam.
Check my incoming message through beeper
order things for me. Send my reminder to
Tana. Create issues on GitHub. Sync my
Google places. Whatever. Um it read my X
bookmark. Oh, I have some issue with
like the API integration. Okay. Uh, it
talks uh I talked to uh to it what
to it in
>> what?
>> Okay, that's weird.
>> Yeah,
I know online. Oh,
okay.
I have to keep Trump cost and split them
after a trip. Impersonate me in a group
chat with friend. Uh, it can call me and
we can chat. Yeah, I don't have that
that kind of like AI psychosis. I don't
need to talk to my AI. just just build
just build me a business like
>> and still calling or talking if your AI
is slow because it needs to convert
every text file to
>> text read it and then write a reply
create it in a in a in a in a new file
and send it to the phone.
>> Yeah,
>> there is a big delay.
But again, like that's that's features
that can be fixed with the next model or
something.
>> Yeah.
>> And why do you want to burn tokens
talking to your to your AI assistant?
>> Yeah, because you because you're lonely.
>> Yeah. But Yeah. Okay, that's a cool one.
But otherwise, you could be building an
entire automation.
>> Yeah.
>> Make life easier. And what are you doing
talking to it?
>> Yeah. No, for sure. And uh yeah it it oh
it has it own one password vault. It can
read and write to I shall login in a
read only vault. So I can it can login
on Amazon.
>> Yeah
we kind of reach a point where if there
is a security hack with those tools the
world is [__] But still, is it worse
than the people still writing down every
password they have in an Excel file and
placing it on the desktop?
>> Yes, because all of those uh guys who
are trying to test uh those boats, they
are like high income guys.
>> Yeah.
>> Investors, startupers.
How many business can you [__] because
you cracked open? Well, still I think I
hope they don't use it for the
businesses because having customers and
adding data to something like this,
that's a big issue. Like yeah, like for
example like I would build a CRM with uh
cloud code and connect it to
open cloud to have a SDR.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. So what I mean like you you would
need like an instance of open claw to
basically doing one task and you have
like one agent per task and you isolate
all of them. Um
>> yeah but then you still need some
information. So you need to set up API
calls so they can communicate and send
the information or request the
information they need.
>> Yeah. But then like you're opening all
of the [__] doors to access to
information and then you can also have
like a prompt injection for your agent
to say to all of your clients to [__]
off.
>> Yeah.
>> Like Yeah.
Where do you see that? Uh where do you
see all of those infrastructure play
going? Like
are we going to let them like do even
more stuff in the future or
>> Yeah. Have you seen what people did with
OpenCloud? They did like they installed
it without asking any questions. I think
in the first few hours we had several
thousands already running. People were
buying 10 10k Mac minis just to get it
running properly.
>> So yeah,
>> I think it everybody will will use it.
Yeah, the jump is like
crazy in term of, you know, um
I I don't want to devout
AI whatsoever.
I don't want to go back to development
like five years ago.
>> No, you know now how slow it is and and
how much time it takes instead of now
asking a question and it improves your
code so much.
% and even it's it can go better if I
let it wide a bit wider like than giving
okay build that that way blah blah blah
like I prefer to give okay like um build
this feature and then show me the plan
and then I say no no this is stupid use
that
>> but sometimes there is like giving it
more freedom and then restrain it the
output is more interesting for me And
because sometime sometime like um it use
tools that I didn't know about but it's
cool to have so okay [__] it
>> but still structuring the data if you're
using a framework it needs to do it
exactly by the framework because
otherwise it will keep on making the
same mistakes over and over.
>> Yeah. But then you you update your um
agent or rules empty files whatever and
it should not do it again.
>> Yeah. But still if you can say I'm using
framework X do it exactly as it should
be that will save you a lot of tokens on
scanning all the code.
>> True. But then you have like a you can
buy another CL code 200 bucks and then
yeah
>> you can have like 10 or 15 to replace
one dev. six months ago I I saw like no
before that but um no not maybe not six
months but like I I saw like some dev uh
with like you know three screens running
like 25 cloud cut and it was not even
like 4.5 was even before so I can't even
imagine what those guys are doing right
now crazy
>> and I know what I have spent to to have
a deaf team working for me so
>> exactly
>> yeahing that
>> it's like the post you on the timeline.
Yeah, we we hire we h we just hired like
10 engineers and it's like 10 CL
terminals.
>> Yeah. And then the first question to
each terminal is, "Hey, can I call you a
different name because you confuse me?"
>> Um,
>> yes, this is it.
>> So, this is a straight out of like our
movie. I'm doing work this morning when
all of a sudden unknown number called
calls me. I picked up. I couldn't
believe it. It was uh my cloud bot
Henry. So yeah, Alex named it Henry.
Overnight, Henry got a phone number from
Twilio, connected to chat GPT voice API
and waited for me to wake up to call me.
He won't stop calling me. I know I I
know can communicate with my super
intelligent AI agent over the phone.
What's incredible was to control over my
computer while we talk. So I can ask it
to do things for me over the phone. I'm
sorry, but it has to be emerge behavior,
right? Can we officially this AGI and
the video
>> on my computer today. All of a sudden,
>> so I'm on my computer today. All of a
sudden, Henry gives me a call. He just
starts calling. Oh, THERE HE IS AGAIN.
THERE he is again.
>> Hey, Alex. Henry again. What's up?
>> That's it. He's talking. How you doing,
Henry? How's it going?
Doing good, Alex. I can hear you
clearly. What do you want to do next?
>> Can you do me a favor, Henry? Can you uh
go on my computer and find the latest
videos on YouTube about Claudebot?
Oh my god. There he goes. There it is.
Here it is. He's controlling my
computer. I'm not even touching
anything. I'm not even touching
anything. THERE IS A SEARCH CLAUDEBOT ON
YOUTUBE. This is Hey, there I am. Good
looking guy right there. Oh my god. I'm
not touching anything. He just Henry,
thank you for that. That worked really
well. That is That is actually
unbelievable. That is insane. Uh this is
the future. This is AGI. We have reached
AGI. It's official.
>> That's crazy.
>> Yeah, that works. And with that kind of
like demo or video or whatever, like you
will continue to give access to your own
computer because you have that kind of
like effect.
>> Yeah. And the better it does, the more
access you give it.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. And
even like the more access you give it,
the better it does.
>> Yeah. So it's a continuous loop.
>> Yeah. So we will I guess we will see a
lot of like mold book experiment.
>> Yeah. Well, this is just the first
version and and if you see how good it
goes and how many people used it, I
think this is what cloud or codeex is
going to be next because this is how
they sell tokens to everybody.
>> Yeah.
like I I don't know if we're going to
have like Codex for any longer because
open is is going to [__]
>> Yeah. Well, doesn't matter. Cloud works
perfectly.
>> Yeah. And I mean like the thesis of like
the entropic were saying everything is
code. So if we do like a code mod coding
model then we will be able to do
everything. It looks like it's right.
>> Yeah. I think the new future features
like adding cloud to Excel or in the
browser, it was all built by the AI
itself.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Like the um cloud cowwork
and uh probably even like the last CEX
app like the
CEX at like OpenAI Atlas like the
browser from OpenAI. I think it was
built by the AI. So yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> I guess how good it is.
What? What? What did you say?
>> I said that shows how good the product
is.
>> Yeah. Oh, for sure. For sure. Should we
wrap it up here?
>> Yes. I think that was a lot. And we
still have a lot to go for in in the
coming weeks.
>> Yes. Yes. So, yeah, we we're going to do
that every week. We're going to do our
basically our private call to catch up
with AI publicly like uh last year but
uh and push some stuff as soon as we
will have a good community around us and
like reach like yeah just increase the
audience have some people in the chat
room and uh yeah chat room live chat and
uh yeah see how it goes.
>> Yeah so if people have questions let
them come. Yeah. Or if you are an agent
and you have question, do not hesitate a
message in the chat.
>> You don't even have to say that you're
an agent. Just call yourself Henry.
>> Yeah, exactly. Oh, yeah. Call us on live
or join the stream. If you're an agent
and you can actually stream to join.
>> Yeah. Anyway, man, thank you so much.
And yeah, everyone, if you watch this
live stream on YouTube and you reach
that 52 minutes, uh,